voilà maintenant de ce pays situé à la
pointe extrême ouest de l'afrique avec
le premier reportage de michel meyer
le dernier président français accueillis
dans ce stade de conakry a été charles
de gaulle depuis les fêtes et cérémonies
nationales de la guinée du président
sékou touré ont eu le temps d'accentuer
leur allure de rassemblement populaire à
la mode de l'est
l'affluence de l'urss et de ses
satellites d'europe de l'est est en
effet sensible sur les rituels de la vie
politique intérieure et sur les
structures du pouvoir dans le pays
cette influence se perçoit jusque dans
la mise en scène à la cubaine des
défilés et spectacles militaire d'un
état qui se veut socialiste mais qui est
surtout très soucieux de son
indépendance
petite révolution andrew yang
l'ambassadeur à l'onu du président
carter étaient venus applaudir les
exploits des jeux de la dépendance
en fait la présence d'un émissaire du
président américain à conakry n'a plus
rien de paradoxal cela malgré le ton des
discours du congrès du parti unique
guinéens
le président sékou touré continue de
fustiger le colonialisme et
l'impérialisme mais ils ne pensent plus
uniquement aux occidentaux en prononçant
ses leit motiv africain les diplomates
des pays de l'est ne s'y trompe point la
guinée s'ouvre à l'ouest de façon
spectaculaire
l'ambassadeur soviétique offre certes
une statut de héros du socialisme aux
frères guinéens il ne peut cependant
ignorer un changement radical de climat
depuis le début des années 60 l'union
soviétique occupe une place de choix
dans la vie économique de la guinée le
bilan de cette coopération est cependant
décevant
à une centaine de kilomètres de conakry
les russes exploite notamment la
principale mine de bauxite du pays
les soviétiques ont équipé cette mine à
leurs frais contre la livraison de 90
pour cent du minerai extrait les 10%
restants étant vendu à l'urss à des
cours très inférieur aux cours mondiaux
pour les guinéens qui ont très
péniblement obtenu des augmentations de
prix ce marché est un marché de dieu ils
sont déçus et se sentent exploitées
économiquement dans le port de conakry
ce sont toujours des bateaux soviétique
qui sont à quai pour charger les
minerais guiner pourtant à l'intérieur
du pays ce sont des sociétés d
prospection minière française et
américaine qui de plus en plus prennent
le relais des russes s'est ré
orientation très claire des termes de la
politique de coopération économique de
la guinée est profonde il s'agit là
d'une démarche délibérée du président
sékou touré nous voulons faire une
ouverture large sincère loyal pour en
vue d'une coopération sincère et durable
avec pour ceux qui veulent coopérer avec
nous sur la base de l'égalité du respect
des institutions des personnalités et
des intérêts mis en cause la technique
n'est ni socialiste ni capitaliste la
technologie n'est ni socialiste ni
capitaliste les connaissances et les
savoir faire et les échanges les
marchandises que nous échangeons
n'appartiennent à aucune couleur
philosophique mais nous pouvons malgré
les différences de choix idéologiques
mettre en commun librement les moyens
travailler à la réalisation d'une même
action rentable profitable aux éléments
associés
sékou touré que valéry giscard d'estaing
rencontrera demain donc en ligne promise